Okay, let's recap what we've
learned about Q-Learning.
First, let's consider what
it takes to build a model.
First step is define states,
actions, and rewards.
So states are combinations
of our features.
Actions are buy, sell, do nothing.
And rewards are some type of return.
Next you choose the training period and
you iterate over that
training period and
update your Q-table on each iteration.
When you reach the end of that
training period you backtest
to see how good the model is and
you go back and
repeat, until the model
quits getting better.
Once it's converged you stop,
you've got your model.
Testing the model is simple you
just backtest it on later data.
Remember we're always training
on one set of data and
then testing on later data.
And that's it.
I hope you enjoyed the lesson.